vial et c'est l'impression que j'ai
blanchi en fait je fais pas une au
brésil
ça c'est cool bon tout cas elle mange
pas trop à cette petite caméra de
smartphones en pense quoi
ça a l'air pas mal du tout
enfin les films
ouais ouais on joue là dedans ça marche
très bien votre ces fissures la cada
bravo
[Musique]
il ya quelques temps je vous ai parlé du
raid minutes 5 suis pas si vous en
souvenez c'est un smartphone car
vraiment cartonné et qui est vraiment eu
un très grand succès un smartphone de
chien est sorti ya pas très longtemps
leur ennemi de petites pro alors je me
suis dit qu'est ce qu'on va faire et
bien on va le tester on va regarder un
peu ce cas dans beat parce qu'au final
ce rémy notre syspro n'ai jamais rien
d'autre que l'évolution du renmin note 5
évolution avec quelques changements
donc il est là lab et ela ce que je
propose c'est de le tester de regarder
quelles sont les différences par rapport
aux originaux de 5 et au final est ce
qu'il vaut mieux aller sur ce raid mine
de dix pros ou alors est ce qui fait
raser sur le ré mineur 5
on va pas tourner autour du pot entre
leurs ennemis note 5h30 notice pro il ya
quasiment pas changement le seul vrai
gros changements que vous avez c'est le
design avant c'est-à-dire un écran avec
une encoche que le rémi not track
n'avait pas très mignonne 5 vous aviez
une bordure sur le holà al assad et la
bordure en eau la bordure en bas pas
plus pas moins
sans rémy notice pro vous avez la petite
encoche ici ce qui lui permet de gagner
en taille de l'écran vous passez d'un
écran de 5 99 pouces un écran de 6,26
pouces c'est toujours une dali ps c'est
toujours du lcd
la définition est un peu supérieure
forcément vous êtes plus de pixels la
cdu 2280 par 1080 pixels 403 ppp ratio
de 19 9e au lieu d'avoir un ratio de 18
9e en termes de design n'y a pas grand
chose qui change le dow reste le même
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour enlever ce
truc très moche derrière lara la capteur
d'empreinte digitale au centre double
caméra là par contre le truc qui change
ce qui est aussi intéressant c'est qu'à
l'avant retrouve un double module photo
alors qu'avant on avait un simple module
photo donc au final a réduit nos six
pros qui n'est qu'une évolution duré 2
minutes 5 voilà comme ça vous savez tous
merci revoir bisous à demain pas
exactement
exactement je vous taquine rassurez-vous
pas exactement pas on ne sait pas faux
c'est parfois parce que il n'y a pas
d'évolution majeure la batterie c'est la
même 4000 willian paire eur vous allez
garder une journée en fonction de votre
utilisation
le soc c'est exactement le même on est
sur un stand dragon's 636 côté gpu c'est
toujours une adreno 509 par contre
différence au lieu d'avoir kajiya drame
vous passez à 3 giga de ram là dessus
alors rassurez vous on voit absolument
pas la différence s'est faite est sûr en
tout
le score est le même en un score de 117
1667 alors qu'avec leur ai dit de 2,5
on avait un score de 116000 et des
brouettes autant le dire franchement ces
mêmes résultats
donc au final 3 giga de ram 4 j g ça
change quoi ya l'histoire donc si au
final la différence se fait pas en terme
de performance elle se fait surtout en
terme d'affichage en termes de
visionnage et en termes de multimédia
parce que c'est vraiment la tendance de
cette fin d'année même depuis le début
de l'année je dirais si d'avoir des
écrans de plus en plus grands et d'où le
fait d'avoir l'encoche donc forcément
leurs ennemis notre si ce qui arrive
après leur ennemi note 5 arrive avec un
plus grand écran pour l'aspect
multimédia
ça c'est ma vidéo dure et demi notre 5
je peux effectivement venir zoomer et
vous voyez que saviez pas du tout propre
et au niveau de l'encoche north en terme
de place utile lorsque vous regardez vos
vidéos
c'est franchement la même chose par
rapport aux ennemis notre 5 donc au
final c'est encore elle vous apporte pas
grand chose de ce point de vue la banque
offre sans tout vous servir pour des
parties de gaming comme dans pib gélas
typiquement vous avez sur le côté
l'encoche donc l'écran va vraiment juste
sur le côté pour toute la partie utile
et ça c'est plutôt pas mal vont profiter
boire toutes vos informations en
bon c'est plutôt pas mal ce qui n est
encore qu elle rompt pas ce qu'il ya des
tests balade et testeront là dessus
aussi bon puisqu'on parle de multimédia
on va se poser la question de l'audio
vous avez encore alors qu'ils se situent
juste là il ya dix ans c'est assez
appréciable là dessus ce qui est plutôt
cool aussi
c'est qu'elle est prise jack donc
forcément pour l'audio on va tester et
on va regarder si le rendu est cool
louis n'en sait écouter mon corps il ya
du son il ya du son et en plus le
spectre est vachement bien donc ça pour
le multimédia que ce soit au niveau du
haut parleur mono parce que forcément là
dessus on n'a qu'à haut parleur mono qui
se situe là au niveau du jack
le son est cool en termes de caméras et
il ya du changement et pas du changement
à l'arrière vous avez une 12 mégapixels
plus une 5 mégapixels qui marche très
bien l'ouverture et la même cf 1.9 ça
fonctionne en faible luminosité s'est
pas non plus complètement dingue par
contre là où c'est tout nouveau à
l'avant une caméra de 12 mégapixels + 2
mégapixels alors qu'avant vous aviez une
13 mégapixels donc c'est plutôt pas mal
l'idée pour les selles fils est d'abord
un effet de bloquer un mode portrait et
ça c'est plutôt pas mal et de l'avoir
surtout du point de vue vraiment
matériel et pas que logiciel moi ce que
j'adorais dessus c'est la fonction
redresser c'est à dire que votre photo
vous la prenez vous tu as un petit peu
de travail à lui va le reconnaître il va
nous adresser votre photo ça je trouve
ça vraiment bien des petites
fonctionnalités mais pour avoir des
photos toujours réussi c'est franchement
bien ce que je vous propose c'est de
regarder directement ce que ça dit en
termes de photo ou une vidéo
pas encore sorti en france voilà
monsieur c'est ben ouais ça c'est du
métier
ça c'est du métier monsieur honneur ça
c'est l'artisanat c'est ça qu'on veut
voir s'il est encore des cheveux de
couleur de cheveux
il date de quelle année là ton mac
2004 2004 et consulats et vintage de
chez vintage et tu sais quoi il était
bon quand même avec les américains c'est
encore la gueule j'ai l'impression que
j'ai blanchi en fait une raison ça c'est
cool
en tout cas elle marche pas trop mal
cette petite caméra de smartphones
n'importe quoi
ça a l'air pas mal plus ou moins
on parle ici
ouais
ouais on soit en ont joué dedans ça
marche très bien votre ces fissures la
cada oui bravo
or et demi note 5 vous avez du bluetooth
5.0 au lieu d'avoir du bluetooth cape
town josh pas franchement la face du
monde mais ça marche plutôt bien
bon ce que je regrette là dessus par
contre c'est que vous n'avez pas de
certification ip67 ip68 globalement
smartphones qui n'est pas étanche
d'un autre côté c'est un smartphone qui
coûtent moins de 250 euros donc éviter
de le jeter dans la flotte serait
dommage il tourne sous android
8.1 oreo avec la surcouche pour
l'instant me 8,9 et on devrait pouvoir
avoir aussi très rapidement la 1000 8/10
dessus avec les changements qui vont
avec ça pourrait être plutôt cool je
produis là est dispo en version globale
s'il vous intéresse vous invite à aller
faire un petit tour chez mon partenaire
dite molle je vous hais les liens en bas
dans la description vous pouvez y aller
garantie européenne enfin vous êtes
vraiment tranquille là dessus c'est une
version globale donc un smartphone en
français il fonctionne très bien sur les
banques françaises vous ne serez donc
pas déçu et il est dispo au tarif de 240
euros je crois en plus qu'à une promo
cependant chez dick mol donc allé voir
franchement ça devrait le faire
pas grande révolution au niveau du
successeur du raid minaude 5 leur
éminente syspro fonctionnent bien et
fonctionnent très bien c'est vraiment
d'une mise à jour c'est une évolution à
l'ordre c'est assez bizarre d'avoir
cette mise à jour dont la même année
parce que leurs ennemis note 5 est
arrivé en début d'année là on arrive
directement avec un rémy nos six pros en
octobre 2018 pourquoi pas de toute façon
pourquoi pas se renier notre 5 était
vraiment déjà très intéressant je pense
que le fait que leurs ennemis note
syspro arrive ça va faire baisser les
prix
dur et demi notre 5 est aussi un
excellent smartphone je vous invite à
aller voir la vidéo que j'ai réalisé
dessus pour voir un petit peu et vous
faire un avis vous allez pas franchement
vous serez pas déçus alors cette mise à
jour est quand même assez bien réussi le
fait d'avoir un écran un peu plus grand
avec l'encoche c'est bien joli pour
regarder les vidéos ça va pas vraiment
changé la face du monde le design est
toujours le même mot parleurs toujours
mono bon ça va bien ça fonctionne pour
avoir un smartphone à 240 euros
franchement vous ne serez absolument pas
déçu les petites modifications qui
s'opèrent notamment surtout au niveau de
la caméra de cette fille va être bien au
niveau du mode portrait et pour faire
des selphy groupe avec le mode portrait
ça fonctionne et la reconnaissance de
visage
donc ça c'est plutôt cool le détourage
est pas complètement dingue c'est pas
forcément la hausse avec le plus fou une
fois de plus on est sur un smartphone
d'entrée
milieu de gamme pas trop lui en demander
en tout cas moi je vous le recommande
parce que je trouve que c'est vraiment
un excellent produit chez tommy maîtrise
absolument sa copie donc en allant sur
un rallye notice pro vous ne serez
absolument pas déçu dites moi ce que
vous en pensez est ce que vous avez
acheté le rémi note 5 cette année
et qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce raid
mine d'autres syspro est ce qu'il
pourrait vous faire bleus est ce que
vous tentez tout ça tout ça vous marque
et tout ça comme d'hab en bas en
commentaire quant à moi j'ai demandé
vous très bientôt pour un prochain
épisode avec plein de nouveautés plein
d'actus plein d'infos plein de tests
mais croyez moi ici il ya franchement de
quoi faire à bientôt soyez ça je vous
embrasse tous
[Musique]